The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at ocw dot
MIT dot edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to lecture
number six.
In this lecture I would like
to discuss with you the
formulation and calculation of
isoparametric finite elements.
We considered earlier already,
in lecture four, the
calculation all finite
element matrices.
But in that lecture we
considered the generalized
coordinate finite
element models.
The generalized coordinate
finite element models were the
first finite elements derived.
However, I now want to discuss
with you a more general
approach of deriving the
required interpolation
matrices and element matrices.
And this more general approach
is the isoparametric finite
element derivation.
The isoparametric finite
elements that I will be
discussing in this and the
next lecture are, in my
opinion, the most effective
elements currently available
for plane stress, plane strain,
axisymmetric analysis,
three dimensional analysis,
thick and thin shell analysis.
These elements are being used,
for example, in the computer
program [? Aldena ?].
They are also used in other
computer programs and
represent a modern approach
to the solution
off structure problems.
In this lecture, I would like
to talk about the derivation
of continuum elements.
In the next lecture we will talk
about the derivation of
structural elements, [INAUDIBLE]
and central
elements, beam elements.
The basic concept of
isoparametric finite element
analysis, is that we interpolate
the geometry of an
element, and the displacements
of an element in
exactly the same way.
Let us look at the geometry
interpolation.
Here you see for three
dimensional analysis, the
interpolation of the
x-coordinate within the
element, where we use
interpolation functions h i.
Of course these interpolation
functions are unknown and I
will have to show you
how we derive
them for certain elements.
The x i as a nodal
point coordinate.
The x i value for i equals 1,
for example, is nothing else
than the x-coordinate
of nodal point one.
And so on.
So the x i, the nodal point
coordinates for all nodes,
they are given, they are input
in the analysis the way we
have been discussing it in
the previous lecture.
And if we know the h i, we have
a direct relationship for
the x-coordinates within the
element, as a function of the
nodal point coordinates.
Again, I have to show you how
we obtain the h i functions
for the various elements
that we are using.
Similarly, for the y
interpolation and similarly
for the z interpolation.
Having derived the h i functions
we are using in the
isoparametric finite element,
the same functions also to
interpolate the displacements.
Notice that we're having here,
the nodal point displacements
u i, v i, and w i, and here we
have the same interpolation
functions that we already
used in the coordinate
interpolations.
And if the number of nodes
that are used in the
description of the element--
and, in fact, we will see that N
can be a variable, it can be
equal to three, four, five, up
to a large number of nodes.
And in practice we generally
don't go much further than 60.
I mentioned that I want to
discuss in this lecture
continuum elements.
Well, the continuum elements
that we addressing ourselves
to are the truss element, the
two d elements-- plane stress,
plane strain, and axisymmetric
elements--
and then, the 3 d elements for
three dimensional and thick
shell analysis.
These are continuum elements.
We call them continuum elements,
because we only use
u, here u and v, and
here, u v and w--
the displacements--
to describe the internal
element displacements.
We're only using the nodal point
displacements u, u v,
and u v w, for all of the nodal
points to describe the
internal element
displacements.
Structure elements, on the
other hand, also use the
rotations at the nodal point
theta x, theta y, and theta z,
in order to describe the
deformations within the element.
And I will be discussing
structural elements in the
next lecture, so, for the
moment, we do not have any
rotations at the nodes.
Or what we will allow, u v and
w displacements at the nodes.
Typical examples are given
on this Viewgraph.
These are elements that are
available in the computer
program [? Aldena ?].
Here we have a truss element,
a two-noded truss element.
The only displacement of
interest in the truss is the
actual displacement here.
Here we have a three-noded
truss, or cable element.
Here we have a set of two
dimensional elements.
Notice we have triangular
elements here, a triangular
element here.
We have here an eight node
element that is curved.
We can construct curved
elements in the
isoparametric approach.
And here we have a rectangular,
eight node
element, straight sides,
in other words.
These elements are used in plane
stress, plane strain,
and axisymmetric analysis.
In three dimensional analysis
we might be talking about--
we might be using--
such elements such as the
eight node brick.
Each node now has three
displacements, u, v, and w.
This is here a higher order
element, where we have, in
addition to the corner nodes,
we also have mid-side nodes.
You don't need to
have a mid-side
nodes along all sides.
For example here,
I did not put a
mid-side node as an example.
In fact we could simply have
mid-side nodes here, and no
mid-side nodes anywhere else.
I will show you how we
deconstruct these
interpolation matrices in
the next few minutes.
Let us consider, as
a very simple
example, a special case.
And the special case that I
would like to look at is a
truss element, which
is two units long.
In other words, the length from
here to there, is equal
to 1, and similarly the length
from here to there, is also
equal to one.
I'm describing the element with
a coordinate r that I set
equal to zero at the midpoint
of the element, plus one at
the right end and minus
one at the left end.
This is special geometry and
we will later on have to
generalize our approach to more
general geometries where
the length is not equal
to two and the element
might even be curved.
But for instructive purposes,
let's look at
this geometry first.
Similarly, for two dimensional
analysis, I want to look at an
element that has length two this
direction and length two
that direction.
In other words, a generalization
of the concept
that we just looked
at for the truss.
Now we have two dimensions and
in each dimension we have a
length of two.
I embed into this element
an rs-coordinate system.
And this coordinate system now
has its origin here at r
equals zero and s equals zero.
The r-axis bisects this
side, and the s-axis
bisects this side.
Notice that this is a coordinate
system that is
embedded into the element.
We also call that the natural
coordinate system, or the
Isoparametric coordinate
system.
This element, two by two, would
lie in space in an x
xy-coordinate system
as indicated here.
Now for three dimensional
analysis we would proceed in
the same way, then we would
consider an element that is
two by two by two
units long into
each coordinate direction.
And then we would have an
rs-axis and a t-axis coming
out of the transparency in
this particular case.
Well, I want to look at the
truss element, the special
truss element, and the special
two d element.
And I want to show you how
we can construct the
interpolation matrices, the
displacement interpolation
matrices, h i.
These are also the coordinate
interpolation matrices.
I want to show you how we
construct them for the special
elements, how we then can
calculate the strain
displacement interpolation
matrices
for the special elements.
And then I want to go on and
show you how we generalize to
concepts to curved elements.
And once we have discussed the
two dimensional case, I think
you can see yourself how the
concepts are generalized to
the three dimensional case.
Let's look then at our two-noded
truss first.
Here we have once more, the
truss, and we have node one on
the right hand side, node two
on the left hand side.
Our r-coordinate system starts
in the middle of the truss.
Notice what we want to obtain
is that we interpolate our u
displacement via the
interpolations.
U being equal to h i times u i,
the h i are the unknowns.
I want to show you how
we obtain the h i.
The u i are the nodal
point displacements.
In this particular case it would
be here, u two and here
we would have u one.
I in other words, goes
from one to two for
this particular case.
The h i has to be
a function of r.
For a given r, however, we can
evaluate the u displacement if
we have u i is given.
In other words, when u one and
u two are given, then for a
given r, we can evaluate
directly from this relation
the displacement at
that point r.
Well, with two nodes, we
can only have a bi--
only a linear representation
in the displacements.
The h one, from this relation,
must be this function.
Because if we look at this, and
we say let u two be equal
to zero, we would simply
have that u is
equal to h one u one.
Well, therefore, our h one must
look this one, because u
one has its full
strength here.
If we put u one equal to one, we
would have u is equal to h
one, and this would
be the variation.
Similarly, for h two, in this
case, we would have u is equal
to h two u two.
H one is now equal to zero.
If we put you two equal to one,
as I have done in this
particular case, then our linear
variation is indicated
as shown here , and
the function h two
is given right here.
Notice that h two is equal to
zero when r is equal to one.
And h two is equal to one when
r is equal to minus 1.
So, this gives us h two.
The two-noded truss, therefore,
simply has this
description here for the
displacement and the
coordinates.
Remember that we're using the
same h i for displacement and
coordinates.
It simply has this description
where h one and h two are
defined as shown.
Let us now say that we want to
add another node, that we want
to put another node
right there.
In other words, we want to go
from a two-noded description
to a three-noded description.
On one of the earlier
Viewgraphs, you could see a
three-noded cable element.
Well, the way we proceed in the
construction of the h i
functions is as follows.
The two-noded element simply
had this description here.
H one is given as shown
here on the left
side of the blue line.
H two was simply this.
And we knew that we could do
no better than a linear
description in displacements
between two nodes.
However, now we have a third
node right here.
And a third node means that
we can use a parabolic
description in displacements.
Now h three must be equal to one
at the third node and zero
at both sides.
Why?
Well, because, remember we have
u now equal to h i u I,
where i equals one to three.
And if we put u one equal to
zero and u to equal to zero,
we simply have u equals h three
u three, and, therefore,
h three is this function.
I've written it down here when
r is equal to zero its one
when r is equal to minus 1
or plus h three is zero.
So this is our h three.
However, if we now look back to
our earlier description of
h one and h two for the
two-noded element, we remember
that we had a linear
variation here.
That we had a linear variation
here and here.
This one was a linear
variation of h one--
let me take here the green color
to show once more what
we are talking about--
that was our linear variation.
And here, this one here was our
linear variation there.
Well, now with the third node
there, we recognize that, at
this third node our h two--
our actual h two for the
three-noded truss--
must be zero here.
H one must be zero here.
Well, how can we make
it zero here?
We can make it zero by
subtracting from our two-noded
truss h one, one half of this
parabolic description.
And that's what I
have done here.
Similarly, we have to subtract
it here, because then, what we
are doing is we are taking one
half off this parabola, and we
are putting it right on here.
This is one half of the
bottom parabola.
We are putting it on there.
And that brings this point
back to that point.
Remember this is equal to one.
I want one half as a correction
here, and that's
why I take one half of one minus
r squared, to bring this
point back to there.
This total description then,
this total part--
this part here, all
of that together--
is our h one for the three-noded
element, for the
three-noded element.
And similarly, we would
have four h two.
This total part here is this
function here for our
three-noded element.
Now the important point that
I really would like you to
understand is that, we have
started off with a two-noded
element description--
h one only the linear part, h
two only the linear part.
We have constructed the
interpolation function for the
third node, and then we have
corrected the earlier
two-noded interpolation
functions via subtracting a
certain part of the third
interpolation function, in
order to obtain the new
h one and h two for
the three-noded element.
And this is indeed the actual
procedure that we can use very
effectively in constructing
higher order elements.
We are starting off with
the lower order element
descriptions--
the ones shown here dashed with
a dashed line, the linear
part only--
and we add in the higher order
description, and subtract the
correction from the lower
order description.
The correction has to be
subtracted to bring this point
back to zero, because h one
total must now be equal to
zero here, h two total must be
equal to zero here, and this
way we have constructed our new
h one and h two for the
three-noded truss element.
Let's look at the four-noded
element in two dimensions now.
Here we use very similar
concepts.
These are the four nodes
for the element.
The description along a side
is just like we have been
discussing now for the truss,
linear here and linear here.
Notice h one can directly
be written down.
It has to be equal to one here
and zero everywhere else.
This is a function which is
bilinear and which satisfies
these conditions to be equal
to one here and.
Zero at the other nodes.
It is a linear variation along
this side, along this side,
and also across the surface.
In other words, for a given
value of r, we have a linear
variation across here too.
How do we obtain h two?
Well, we simply have to change
the signs over here--
the plus signs here-- in
an appropriate way.
H two shall be equal to one
here zero at all the other
nodes, while we see that this
function satisfies these
conditions, let's put in
r equal to minus 1.
That makes this two, divided
by four, gives us one half.
S has to be equal to plus
1 at this point--
you get another two in here--
so h two is equal to one
right there, and its
zero everywhere else.
Similarly we construct
h three and h four.
Indeed we can immediately
observe that these signs--
plus in both cases here, a minus
here, plus there, minus,
minus, plus, minus-- these signs
correspond to nothing
else in the signs of the r- and
s-coordinates of the nodal
point under consideration.
R and s is plus here, you have
two plus signs here.
R is negative here, you put
a negative sign here.
But s is positive here, you
put a plus sign there.
r and s both are negative here,
so we have two negative
signs here, et cetera.
Let us now see how we construct
from this basic four
node element, which really
corresponds to our basic two
node element in the case of
the truss, how we can
construct higher
order elements.
Well, we proceed in much the
same way as in the truss
formulation.
Here we have a four-noded basic
element and we have
added a fifth node to it.
Now let's look at
this in detail.
Since we now have added a fifth
node here, we know that
we can allow a parabolic
distribution.
In fact, we should allow a
parabolic distribution of
displacements along the side.
Well, if its a parabola along
the side for s being plus 1,
we immediately see that
this function here--
this s equal to plus one, this
is equal to two, knocks out
that one half, we have
a one minus r
squared along the side--
just the same function that we
already had in the truss.
Well, along this direction we
can only vary things linearly
because we have two nodes only
in along these directions.
And this is the reason
why we have to put in
a one plus s here.
The linear variation is
given by one plus s.
And we also notice that when s
is equal to minus 1, in other
words, we are looking at this
side, this function is zero.
When s is equal to plus one,
as we pointed out earlier,
this function here--
this part and that part--
gives us a one together, and we
have simply a one minus r
squared along here.
So, here you can see these
triangles that show the linear
variation along this side.
These parabolas here run really
across here, but with a
different intensity.
The intensity off the parabola
goes down linearly from one at
this end, to is zero
at that end.
This is our h five.
Well, if we have this as our h
five, we remember that our
original h one of the of the
four-noded element had a
linear variation along here,
and also a linear variation
along here.
We will now have to take this
h one and subtract some
correction from it.
In order to make this point here
have zero displacement,
four h one.
Well, what we will do is we take
this h five and subtract
a multiple of h five
from h one.
In fact, you can see since the
original h one is equal to one
half here, we simply have to
subtract one half of this
function to obtain
the new h one.
And this is what I have done
on this Viewgraph.
The h one now is the original
h one that we had.
And we are subtracting one half
of h five, which is one
half of the parabolic
distribution, to bring this
point here down to zero
in displacements.
And that's what we
have done here.
The resulting function
then is shown here.
And our h one for the five-noded
element is shown
right here.
Similarly, for h two--
this is the h two function for
the five-noded element--
interesting to note that h three
and h four are for the
five-noded element, the same as
for the four-noded element.
Because this fifth node lies
between nodes one and two.
And there is no effect
along this side and
along this side here--
along that side four h three and
h four-- so, we have our
original functions also for
the five-noded element.
Let us look now at a
generalization of this concept.
Here we have a typical
nine-noded element.
A very effective element for
many types of applications.
I already show it here in its
curved form, but think of it,
please, as follows.
This is the x-axis.
This is the r-axis.
S is equal to zero
along this side.
S is equal to plus one
S is equal to minus
1 along this side.
R is equal to plus one
along this side.
R is equal to minus one
along the side.
And r is zero along this axis.
So, in the r s description,
in the embedded coordinate
system, this element is still a
two by two squared element.
Well, if we look then at the
interpolation functions, for
this element, they
look as follows.
Now maybe you have difficulty
seeing all this information,
so, please then refer to the
study guide where you'll find
this Viewgraph.
For the four-noded element,
we had these
interpolation functions.
If we want to deal with the
five-noded element, what we
have to do is, we add this
interpolation function.
And--
as I pointed out earlier--
we have to correct our
h one and h two.
But that is all of the
correction that is required.
H three and h four
not corrected--
they are blank spots here, they
are blank spots here.
So, our five-noded element would
have these interpolation
functions now shown in red.
For if we added a sixth node--
and I now should go back to
our earlier picture--
if I wanted to add, in addition
to the fifth node,
also the sixth node.
Well, then, I have to put
another interpolation function
down here, which now
is parabolic in s
and linear in r.
And I have to correct h two and
h three again, these are
the corrections.
So, now I have in green here
shown to you the interpolation
functions off a six-noded
element.
And like that we can proceed
by adding interpolation
functions and correcting
the earlier constructed
interpolation functions
as shown.
Like that we can proceed
to directly obtain the
interpolation functions for
the five-noded, six-noded,
seven-, eight-, and nine-noded
element.
In fact, its also important to
notice that we could have this
node, that node, this node, and
that node, and just h nine
also added.
We could have, in other words,
a five-noded element which
looks like this.
It has this node, that one, that
one, and that one, and
that one in the middle.
Another five-noded element would
be this one, this one,
this one, this one with
that node in there.
So there is no necessity in
having all the nodes below a
certain number.
But we can simply use four
nodes, and then add whichever
nodes we want to have
into the element.
This is, then, how we construct
interpolation functions.
And once we had the h i, we
directly can obtain the h
matrix, the matrix that gives
the displacements in terms of
the nodal point displacements.
Notice that the h
matrix really is
constructed from the hi's.
And the elements of
the b matrix--
the strain displacement
interpolation matrix--
are the derivatives of
the h i or zero.
And I will show you an
example right now.
Because we are using four, we
are still looking at the
special case of a two by two
by two element in a truss
case, only this two.
Plane stress, plane strain,
axisymmetry, two dimensional
analysis, we have
these two two's.
In other words, we're talking
about a two by two element.
And in three dimensional
analysis we would talk about a
two by two by two element.
In these cases, we have x equal
to r, y equal to s, z
equal to t.
So the strains--
which are derivatives with
respect to x the actual
physical coordinates--
can also directly be obtained
by simply taking the
derivative with respect
to r, and then
similarly for s and t.
Let us look at a four node,
two dimensional element.
This is really the element
that we have used in our
earlier example of the
cantilever analysis.
Here we would simply have
that u r s, v r s, are
described as shown.
Notice that in the first row we
are really saying nothing
else than u is a summation
h i u i.
Where i equals one to
four because we have
a four-noded element.
H i u i.
In the second row we are really
saying nothing else
than v being the summation of i
equals one to four h i v i.
And all I have done is I have
taken these hi's and assembled
them into a matrix form to
obtain our h matrix.
This h matrix here--
the entries in that h matrix--
are dependent on the ordering
that you're using here for u
one, v one, u two, et cetera.
With this ordering, these
are the entries.
Notice there are zeroes here,
because the v degrees of
freedom at the nodes have
no contribution to the u
displacement in the element.
Well, if we look at the plane
stress case and want to
construct our b matrix, remember
the b matrix gives
the strains in terms of the
nodal point displacements.
And we remember also that our
epsilon xx is equal to a dy
dx, our epsilon yy is equal to
dv dy and our gamma xy is
equal to a du dy plus dv dx.
Well, if we recognize
these facts.
And we also note again that for
the two by two element, r
is identical to x, s
is identical to y.
Then, we can obtain the epsilon
rr or epsilon xx by
simply taking the derivatives of
the hi's with respect to r.
Notice here, since u is equal
to the summation of h i u i,
dy dr, which is equal to du dx,
is nothing else then the
summation of partial
h i dr u i.
And this part, which runs
from one to four--
i going from one to four--
I simply put right in there.
I proceed similarly
for epsilon yy.
Now I'm talking about the v
displacements, which are
stored after the u
displacements.
That's why I'm looking
here at the second
column, the last column.
And here we have dh one ds,
because we are talking about
the derivative with respect to
y or with respect to s, which
is the same thing.
So here we have the entries
for the epsilon ss part.
Now for the strain part, we are
talking du dy or du ds, dv
dx, dv dr. And all we have to
do in now is take this term
and put it right in there, and
take this term and put it
right in there.
And then the last row
here gives us
the shearing strength.
So this is our b matrix for the
special two by two element.
It is constructed in
a very simple way.
The h i are known, and if we
had five or six or seven
nodes, we would proceed in
exactly the same way.
All we would have to do is
include additional columns in
the b matrix that would give us
the appropriate entries for
strains generated by the
additional nodal point
displacements.
Let us now look how we can
generalize these concepts to
the element that is not,
anymore, in the physical x and
y space, two by two element.
In the physical x and y
space, this element--
four-noded element now--
might look as shown here.
However, what we do is we still
deal with the r- and
s-coordinate system embedded
on the element.
We are on s one here, minus one
s plus one here, r and s
both minus one here, plus
one here s minus one.
So in the natural coordinate
space, the rs space, we still
have a two by two element.
The interpolation of the
displacement therefore--
the interpolation of
the displacements--
even for the distorted element,
is exactly still as
shown here.
Provided we are entering
always with the
appropriate r and s.
H one is a function
of r and s.
So if we look at a point in
the general element, if we
look at a point in the general
element, here, for example, at
such a point.
Because that point has a
specific r and s value.
And if we want to find the
displacement at that point,
well, we would have to put the
r and s value of that point
into h one, h two, h three, h
four, and that gives us then
the displacement at that point,
in terms of the nodal
point displacement.
So, the displacement
interpolation for this element
can still be done in
the r and s space.
However, difficulties arise--
or additional considerations
I should say rather--
arise when we talk about
strains, because the physical
strains that we have to deal
with are derivatives with
respect to x and y, and
not r and s anymore.
Well, so what we have to
do is, use a Jacobian
Transformation.
What we want are the
derivatives with
respect to x and y.
What we can find easily are
derivatives with respect to r
and s on the displacements,
because the displacements are
given in terms of
r and s values.
So, remember u is equal to some
of h i u i and the h i is
a function of r and s, so, we
can directly find derivatives
with respect to r and s of u.
What we cannot find easily are
derivatives with respect to x.
This is the relationship
that we use.
It gives us a transformation
from derivatives of x and y to
derivatives r and s.
A question must immediately be
in your mind, why do we not
write down directly this
relationship, which is given
by the [INAUDIBLE].
If we want d dx of
displacements, why not just
use d dx being equal to d
dr, dr dx, and so on.
Well, the difficultly
is that we cannot
find dr dx very easily.
We have x being this function
of h i x i.
This is the interpolation which
we have to use now.
I mentioned earlier on the
first slide that we
interpolate displacement and
coordinates in the same way.
So, here we have a linear
interpolation of the
coordinates, from this node
to that node, and in
between here too.
So we are using this
interpolation here on the
coordinates.
And we can easily dx dr, but we
cannot easily find dr dx.
You would have to invert this
relationship somehow so that
we have r in terms of x.
Well, it is easier, therefore,
to write this relationship
down, which is really
the chain rule.
This is also the chain rule, its
a chain rule the other way
around, which gives d dr being
equal to d dx, dx dr plus d dy
dy dr, if we multiply
this out.
And its this relationship that
we can use effectively.
Well, this relationship in three
dimensional analysis
would involve a third row
and third column.
In one dimensional analysis we
only talk about one by one.
In other words, in one dimension
analysis for a truss
we just have that entry.
In general we can write it in
this way, where j is the
Jacobian transformation from the
xyz-coordinate system to
the rst-coordinate system.
And since we want these
derivative--
because these derivatives give
us actual strains, we have to
invert this relationship.
Having constructed then, these
derivatives in terms of these
derivatives, which we can find
just as we have done before,
we can now establish the
b matrix in much
the same way as earlier.
And since we now have h and b
matrices for an element--
these are a function
r, s, and t--
we would perform the
integration.
And now I'm referring to
the integration of
the stiffness matrix.
Remember k is equal to b,
transposed cb over the volume.
Now notice that since the b
matrix that we are using in
here is a function of r and s in
a two dimensional analysis.
And r runs from minus one to
plus one, and s runs from
minus one to plus one.
We now have to use a
transformation also on dv to
integrate over the r s volume.
And that integration--
and that dv element is expressed
as shown here--
and that is given to us from
mathematical analysis.
So basically what we are saying
here is that we are
replacing this integral over
the physical volume by an
integral minus one to plus one,
minus one to plus one.
And that signifies from minus
one to plus one over r and
over s, if we had a three
dimensional analysis we would
have another integral
sign here.
B transposed now r and s
function of r and s, cb,
function of r and s.
And then our dv, now in
terms of r and s.
So this is how we really
do things.
And remember this dv here, this
dv, is that one there.
This integration is effectively
performed using
numerical integration and
I will discuss later on.
Let's look once at the Jacobian
transformation for
some very simple examples--
the Jacobian transformation for
just to make things
a little clearer.
In this case we really have
taken our two by two element
and we have stretched it
into the x- and y-axes.
That stretching is giving us a
three here and a two there
because our two by two element
has a length of two here, and
six divided by two
gives us three.
Similarly here we have stretched
the element by a
factor of two.
This relationship here is,
in general, calculated--
the j is, in general,
calculated--
as shown here.
And the result of that, by
putting these interpolations
into there are these
values here.
Physically what these mean
is a stretching, in this
particular case, into
the x- and y-axis.
Somewhat--
the case where we cannot
directly--
not easily directly write down
to j matrix is this one.
Here we would go through the
actual evaluation the way I
have indicated it.
In other words, we would
go through this actual
evaluation, substituting from
here and of course for y also.
And this would be the result
Notice that we now have a
stretching here of three,
compression from a two length
to a one length--
therefore we have a one half
here-- and there's also an
angle change that gives us the
off-diagonal element here.
Another interesting case here,
as an example, we have the
same lengths here--
two same lengths here-- but a
distortion in the element
because this node two
has come down from
there to its midpoint.
And the resulting Jacobian
is given here.
Now notice that that Jacobian is
a function r and s, so the
inverse, which is used in the
construction of the b matrix
would also be a function
of r and s.
A particularly interesting case
is the one where we shift
nodes to advantage.
See here we have
our original--
our three-noded element that we
talked about already-- in
the r space now.
Its a truss element.
And let's say that in our actual
physical space, we have
this node there, the three
node there, and
the two node there.
The element in the actual
physical space
has a length of l.
We have taken this node and
shifted it to the quarter
point of the element, to the
quarter point of the element.
What I will show you right now
is that by having done so-- by
having taken this node from its
midpoint and shift it over
in the actual physical space
to the quarter point--
we will find that the strain has
a singularity here of one
over square root x.
This is a very important point
which can be used in the
analysis of fracture problems,
because we know that in the
we have a one over square root
x singularity at a crack tip.
And, if we want to predict the
actual stress there or the
displacement around the crack
tip, it can be of advantage to
use this fact, shifting nodes to
quarter points in order to
capture the stress singularity
more accurately.
Well let me show you then how
this strain or stress
singularity comes about.
If we look at this element
here and we use our
interpolation on the
coordinates, this
would be the result.
Now, notice that we
have substituted
the x i values here.
X one is zero, x two is l,
x three is l over four.
We have substituted those values
and directly come up
with this result.
Well, we can see that
this indeed is true.
Let's put r equal
to plus one n.
In other words, the right
hand side node--
for the right hand side node--
and we would have a two here
squared, gives us four, goes
out with that four.
So at i equals plus 1 we have
x equal to l, which
is correct of course.
Let's put i equal to minus one
n, we find x is equal to zero.
Let's put i equal to
zero n we find x is
equal to l over four.
In other words, this has been a
simple check in that we have
the right interpolation--
geometry interpolation--
for this element.
Our j now is simply, dx
dr, X is given here.
If you take the differentiation
of that you
get the two in front that gives
l over two times one
plus r, this value here,
in other words.
Then our b matrix is
constructed by the
inverse of the j--
that is this one--
two times the r derivative of
the interpolation functions.
Of course here we talk only
about one strain.
Remember, in the truss, the only
displacement of concern
is the u displacement and the
strain is simply epsilon xx, a
strain into this
direction also.
Well, this is our
b matrix then.
And if we take our h one,
two, and three, and we
differentiate these--
as indicated here with respect
to r-- we directly obtain
these functions here.
If we now recognize that since
we have x related to r here,
we can also invert this
relationship.
We can write r in terms of x.
And if we have done so we can
take that relationship and put
it right in here.
Then we would get
b in terms of x.
And that's what I
have done here.
The first line shows simply r in
terms of x now, and I have
substituted that r value into
the b matrix and this is there
is the result.
Notice that we have a
strain singularity.
This is the first
element here.
The next element--
this is here--
the next element in b matrix,
and that is the third element
in the b matrix.
Notice that we have in this
element, that one, and that
one the one over square root
x, which means that we have
one over square root
x singularity
at x equal to zero.
Well, this fact is used very
effectively in fracture
mechanics analysis.
Assume that we have crack here
and that we want to analyze
the stress conditions
around that crack.
What we can do is we use now two
dimension elements, as its
a plane stress situation.
We would put a two dimensional
triangular element there and
we shift the midpoint nodes.
This is now very small
here, but I hope
you can still follow.
You shift these midpoint nodes
to the quarter point, just the
way we have been
doing it here.
You are putting the third node
the quarter point and the
result is that at this crack tip
we have a one over square
root x singularity, using
this element layout.
And we know that in fact, there
is a one over square
root x singularity in linear
fracture mechanics analysis.
And so this is an effective
way of capturing this
singularity, and has been used
or is currently being used
very abundantly in practice.
The important point that I
wanted to make really is that
we can shift nodes in the
element to our advantage.
But, we really do that in
specific applications such as
fracture mechanics.
In general we will see later
when I talk about modeling of
finite element systems, in
general, it is most effective
to leave the mid-side nodes at
their physical midpoints.
In other words for an
eight-noded element, two
dimensional analysis, we would
put this mid-node in the
physical space also, actually
at the midpoint.
We would not shift it.
Then the element has good
convergence characteristics
into all directions and this is
really how the element is
used most effectively for
general applications.
However, in specific
applications, such as fracture
mechanics analysis, it can be
of advantage to shift these
mid-side nodes to pick up
certain strain or stress
singularities that
we know do exist.
Now on the last transparency
that I wanted to show you, I
wanted to indicate something to
you that I will be talking
about in later lectures more
abundantly, namely the fact
that we're using numerical
integration.
B, for the k matrix as an
example, is once again now a
function of r and s.
This part here is also a
So we have here function
of r and s.
and we have here also a
function of r and s.
So this f matrix here is
a function of r and s.
Notice that the b also includes
the inversion of the
j, the Jacobian matrix.
It includes the inversion of
the j, because we had to
construct the x and y and z
derivatives from the r, s, and
t derivatives.
So, what we do in practical
analysis is that we use
numerical integration to
evaluate the k matrix.
I have indicated that here
schematically, if you look at
this element here.
What we do is, we evaluate the
f matrix-- this is a matrix.
In two dimensional analysis we
would only run over i and j.
I is this direction.
J is that direction.
In three dimensional analysis,
which is in general analysis,
we run i, j, and k this way.
We evaluate the f matrix
here at specific
points, r, s, and t.
T now being this axis.
And then multiply that f matrix
by certain weight
constants and sum these
contributions over all i, j,
and k, in order to obtain an
accurate enough approximation
to the actual stiffness
matrix.
The order of approximation
with which we obtain the
actual stiffness matrix--
or rather how closely the
numerically calculated
stiffness matrix approximates
the actual stiffness matrix--
depends on, number one, how many
integration points we are
using and what kind
of integration
scheme we are using.
These points here correspond
to the Gauss numerical
integration.
In this case for two dimensional
analysis, we would
use a two by two integration.
In other words, i and j would
both run from one to two.
K is not applicable and we would
have altogether four
evaluations off the Fs here.
Multiply each of them by
weighting factors, which has
been derived for us by Gauss
some long time ago.
And summing up these
contributions gives us a close
enough approximation
to the k matrix.
Of course, the question of how
many points we have to use,
what integration scheme we
should use, is a very
important one.
We must use enough integration
points to get a close enough
approximation to the actual
stiffness matrix and I will be
addressing those questions
in a later lecture.
This is all I wanted to
say in this lecture.
Thank you very much for
your attention.